m'a apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
après l'échec en commission paritaire
mixte le projet de loi sur le pass
vaccinale antico vide est de nouveau
devant les députés le texte devrait être
à nouveau réexaminée de mon sénat ou en
début de semaine prochaine son adoption
ne devrait donc pas avoir lieu avant le
17 janvier alors que demain de nombreux
opposants au texte manifesteront une
nouvelle fois partout en france
[Musique]
autre manifestation aujourd'hui au mali
pour protester contre les sanctions de
la cedeao mesures punitives de
l'organisation ouest africaine pour
inciter l'armée a cédé rapidement le
pouvoir aux civils bamako où
paris et bruxelles
reste mais pas à n'importe quel prix
d'après les mots du chef de la
diplomatie française à l'issue d'une
réunion informelle des ministres
européens des affaires étrangères à
brest bretagne
[Musique]
mobilisation également en tunisie et cet
après midi où plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont bravé l'interdiction de se
rassembler pour célébrer l'anniversaire
de la révolution de jasmin interdiction
mise en place par le président kaïs saïd
pour des raisons sanitaires ce dernier
s'est arrogé les pleins pouvoirs l'été
dernier ce que l'opposition continue de
dénoncer
[Musique]
très bon vendredi à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur rt france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information une
alternative utile c'est ainsi que la
haute autorité de santé qualifie
l'arrivée du nouveau vaccin anti copie
de novavax has vient de donner son feu
vert au sérum du laboratoire américain
et qui va devenir le cinquième à être
disponible en france de quoi inciter les
personnes réticentes se faire injecter
les vaccins
qui ne souhaitent pas des sérums arn
messagers de fighter et moderna
puisqu'il s'agit là d'un vaccin basé sur
des technologies plus classique tout
comme le sérum johansen dont l'instance
sanitaire publie également deux
nouvelles recommandations les premières
injections pourrait avoir lieu début
février d'après le ministère de la santé
et ce alors que le pass vaccinale
poursuit son chemin législatif chaotique
après l'échec en commission paritaire
mixte le texte est revenu cet après midi
devant les députés l'assemblée nationale
qui devrait avoir le dernier mot mais
l'adoption n'aura pas lieu avant le
début de la semaine prochaine plus de
précision avec katia technique devant le
palais bourbon
de nombreux points de désaccord
subsistent en ce jour de deuxième
lecture en séance publique les députés
d'opposition critiquent sans
discontinuer la gestion de la crise
sanitaire comme le républicain yanbu car
qui a exprimé son insatisfaction
vis-à-vis des protocoles sanitaires à
l'école d'autres parlementaires estiment
que le pass vaccinale n'aura pas tant
d'effets bénéfiques car la protection
qui est conférée par les vaccins
n'interviendra qu'après le pic
épidémique de mikron il souhaite aussi
une clause de revoyure au 28 février que
le gouvernement ne souhaite pas il pense
qu'il faut plutôt renforcer les mesures
barrières et imposer le ffp2 dans les
transports ou les lieux clos député
insoumis eric coquerel a quant à lui
blâmé la société du qr code alors les
désaccords sont nombreux les principaux
et bien les républicains souhaitent par
exemple que le pass vaccinale n'est plus
voix au chapitre des que les
hospitalisations liées aux copies de 19
passe sous la barre des 10000 ils ne
veulent pas non plus de la vérification
d'identité dans les établissements il
est alors maintenant question
un papier un document tiers avec une
photo plutôt que la vérification en soi
de papiers d'identité autre désaccord et
bien les sanctions pour les entreprises
qui ne respecteraient pas le télétravail
le seul point d'accord finalement le
pass vaccinale qui serait réservée
seulement aux plus de 16 ans en tout cas
cette discussion pour les amendements
intervient après l'échec de la signature
d'un texte hier en commission mixte
paritaire entre sénateurs et députés il
faut aussi tenir compte que ce sera de
toute façon l'assemblée nationale qui
tranchera et le tribunal administratif
de nantes à lui trancher le port du
masque n'est plus obligatoire en
loire-atlantique décision similaire à
celle de paris et de versailles ces
dernières soeurs qui suspendent aussi
cette obligation dans la capitale et les
yvelines alors que six cent mille
français verront leurs passes sanitaire
invalidée à partir de demain faute de
rappel le gouvernement peinent de plus
en plus à faire appliquer sa politique
sanitaire
romain qu elle
c'est un nouveau revers sanitaires pour
le gouvernement face à la recrudescence
des cas de kovy 19 l'exécutif avait
incité les préfets à agir par exemple en
imposant de nouveaux le port du masque
dans certains lieux ce jeudi le tribunal
administratif de paris a annoncé la
suspension de l'arrêté préfectoral
rendre obligatoire le port du masque
dans la capitale est en vigueur depuis
le 31 décembre
une décision motivée par le caractère
disproportionné des restrictions mises
en place par le préfet didier lallement
la mesure ne répond pas aux impératifs
de stricte proportion risques sanitaires
encourus cette décision n'est pas
équilibrée au regard des contraintes
physiques et respiratoires que
représente le port du masque
systématique en extérieur mais aussi du
risque d'amendé des entraves en matière
de communication et de vie sociale les
décisions de justice prises dans les
yvelines à paris et ce vendredi en
loire-atlantique risque de faire
jurisprudence
mardi le conseil d'état avait déjà
indiqué que les préfet ne pouvait
imposer le port du masque en extérieur
que sous certaines conditions dont les
rues de la capitale cette suspension est
accueilli avec le sourire je pense que
c'est plutôt agréable parce que comme ça
on peut respirer et normalement après
c'est vrai que même quand ils avaient
été rendus obligatoires les savait pas
été spécialement bien transféré comme
information donc bâton le portait moi la
première mais du coup franc c'est vrai
que de mon point de vue ça va changer
grand chose mais au niveau des lois
c'est dire basta monde qui ont récemment
plus de liberté ne faut pas forcément
l'intérêt que d'avoir le port du masque
dans la rue sachant qu'on est dans un
endroit enfin ouvert il n'y a pas
forcément plus de contaminations autres
donc enfin moi je trouve ça positif un
peu arrêtés préfectoraux suspendu gronde
des enseignants débat parlementaire à
rallonge autour du pass vaccinale à
trois mois de la présidentielle le
gouvernement peine à faire accepter sa
stratégie contre le coc vie 19 à la
population alors que les nouveaux cas
journalier covit dépasse régulièrement
la barre des 300 milles depuis plusieurs
jours la situation épidémique dans les
prisons dégénère dans un courrier
adressé au garde des sceaux la
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté appelle à soulager
les centres pénitentiaires les
précisions avec ta vie de khalifa devant
le ministère de la justice place vendôme
à paris
surpopulation carcérale promiscuité
insensé flambées épidémiques épuisement
physique et morale voilà comment on peut
résumer en quelques mots la situation
actuelle dans les établissements
pénitentiaires français c'est d'ailleurs
avec ces termes précis que dominique
simonnot la contrôleur général des lieux
de privation de liberté interpellent
trois ministres à travers plusieurs
courrier rendu public
elle implore l'exécutif d'agir
rapidement en dépit de l'extrême
virulence de l'actuelle vague de
l'épidémie et l'application de nouvelles
mesures pour tenter de maîtriser la
situation sanitaire pas un mot n'a été
prononcé par les autorités sur la
condition pourtant très inquiétante des
prisons des centres de rétention
administrative des locaux de garde à vue
et des hôpitaux psychiatriques
le cglpl le déplore et estime impératif
d'alerté nouvelle fois les ministres de
la santé de la justice et de l'intérieur
un cri d' alerte justifiée au vu de la
progression des chiffres au 4 janvier
863 cas avaient été détectés parmi les
quelque soixante dix mille détenus
français 1029 parmi le personnel sur
environ 1 40 mille des bilans qui ont
triplé en quelques jours les foyers à se
multiplient en témoigne la maison
d'arrêt de villepinte en
seine-saint-denis qui comptait cent
soixante dix neuf détenus positif au
courant d'un virus à cette même période
sur
988 détenu actuellement le plus fort
taux de contamination pour kobe 19 dans
les prisons françaises livrée à
elle-même la direction a pris ses
propres dispositions activités
collectives retirer travail aux ateliers
supprimer combinaison intégrale et
masques ffp2 distribués aux surveillants
lorsqu'ils sont dans les bâtiments de
détention et aux détenus qui doivent
continuer à travailler par ailleurs à
des parois en plexiglas ont été
installés dans les parloirs
organisations syndicales demandent à
l'administration pénitentiaire de
définir un cadre beaucoup plus générale
avec des limitations aujourd'hui une
véritable urgence à prendre des mesures
de bon sens et de limitation à
l'intérieur des établissements et ça
passe nécessairement par une doctrine
beaucoup plus nationale qui soit prise
par le directeur d'administration
pénitentiaire lui même un plan global
qui s'apparenterait aux mêmes mesures
prises par l'exécutif en mars 2020 au
début de l'épidémie c'est ce que
souhaite également dominique simonnot ce
qui permettrait de libérer les personnes
détenues proches de leurs fins de peine
et de différer les incarcérations qui
peuvent l'être pour éviter la surcharge
dans les prisons et limiter les foyers
épidémiques autre point important la
vaccination
57,6 % des détenus ont bénéficié d'au
moins une dose de vaccin contre le coc
vide 1 contre eux près de 79 % de
l'ensemble des français au même moment
un écart beaucoup trop important surtout
en regard de la promiscuité qui frappe
cette population aujourd'hui
l'administration pénitentiaire engagé
des discussions avec le ministère de la
santé puisque les soins je rappelle en
milieu carcéral relève du ministère de
la santé et non de l'administration
pénitentiaire afin qu'il y ait une
véritable politique un peu plus large et
un peu plus vaste peut-être
d'information de la population pénale
concernant la vaccination
ce qui a été remarqué tout de même par
rapport à ça depuis le début de la
semaine c'est qu'il ya une sorte de
relance de reprise de la campagne
vaccinale au milieu carcéral puisqu'on à
une augmentation de 10 % du nombre des
vaccinations par rapport à la semaine
précédente une des conséquences directes
de cette flambée épidémique et pour le
personnel dans les prisons et qui a vu
une réduction drastique de ses effectifs
due à la multiplication de ces cas
contacts d'où une gestion plus difficile
des établissements le gouvernement reste
pour l'instant au muet et plus
particulièrement eric dupond moretti
pourtant au sommet de la hiérarchie et
pénitentiaire avec ces courriers
dominique simonnot espère inciter le
garde des sceaux à prendre ses
responsabilités
voilà faire n'en finit plus de rebondir
novak djokovic pourra-t-il jouer l'open
d'australie lundi après l'annulation son
visa il ya une semaine le serbe avait
finalement été autorisée par la justice
australienne à rentrer sur le territoire
mais canberra on a décidé autrement en
annulant de nouveau tout à l'heure sont
bizarres et président serbe accuse ce
sont le premier ministre australien je
cite de maltraiter le numéro un mondial
yoann street
tout est à refaire pour novak djokovic
le serbe avait gagné une première manche
devant le tribunal de melbourne mardi
dernier mais le gouvernement australien
pouvait à tout moment sortir son droit à
l'expulsion après quelques jours de
réflexion le ministre de l'immigration à
l'ex ocpt a décidé de l'utiliser ce
vendredi comme il l'a fait savoir dans
un communiqué j'ai exercé mon pouvoir en
vertu de l'article 133 c de la loi sur
l'immigration pour annuler le visa
détenus par monsieur novak djokovic pour
des raisons de santé et de bon ordre au
motif qu'il était dans l'intérêt public
de le faire le gouvernement morrison
s'est fermement engagé à protéger les
frontières de l'australie en particulier
en ce qui concerne la pandémie de kovy
19 si cette décision est loin d'être une
surprise pour les australiens
c'est pourtant un sentiment
d'incompréhension qui demeure
pourquoi il lui met toute cette pression
je veux dire laisser le gars joue et il
est déjà là et juste le laisser faire ce
qu'il a besoin de faire c'est tout
il a gagné son procès de manière juste
et équitable alors pourquoi le
gouvernement en fait tout un plat quant
à la réaction de novak djokovic
elle a été immédiate ses avocats ont
décidé de faire appel et c'est un
tribunal d'exception qui s'est tenue
dans la foulée après avoir entendu les
arguments des parties le juge kelly en
charge de la faire a décidé de se
dessaisir du dossier ce sera finalement
le tribunal fédéral qui devra trancher
samedi matin en attendant novak djokovic
est toujours assigné à sa résidence et
sera de nouveau entendu par les services
de l'immigration samedi avant d'aller au
tribunal
des doutes sont émis quant à ces
documents pour son exemption médicale
mauvaise nouvelle pour lui il retournera
ensuite en détention après son audition
et pour certains habitants de serbie
c'est tout simplement de l'acharnement
je suis révolté je suis en colère parce
que je ne m'attendais pas ce qu'ils
traitent le meilleur joueur de tennis au
monde de cette façon ce que novak est en
train de traverser c'est la frustration
de notre nation entière ce n'est pas
normal
l'entourage de novak djokovic espère une
réponse rapide sur sa situation car le
serbe est censé faire son entrée en lice
à l'open d'australie lundi prochain
melbourne les températures atteignent
second des records lors de l'open
d'australie le mois de janvier propice à
la canicule dans de nombreux pays de
l'hémisphère sud du globe une météo rêvé
par certains mais qui se révèle être un
calvaire pour d'autres sandra tshilombo
bassins artificiels lacs rivières tous
les moyens sont bons pour combattre les
fortes chaleurs cette semaine en
argentine le mercure a battu un record
avec plus de 40 degrés dans une grande
partie du pays à buenos aires où ils
n'avaient jamais fait aussi chaud depuis
65 ans les habitants profitent des
différents points d'eau sans oublier les
gestes barrière
il fait vraiment très chaud à cause de
la pandémie actuelle et de la situation
économique
c'est très difficile à vivre nous ne
pouvons pas aller sur nos côtes qui sont
à 400 ou 500 km nous avons donc décidé
de venir ici c'est gratuit il ya une
distance sociale et nous passons un bon
moment
la chaleur a augmenté au cours des 20 à
30 dernières années l'hiver est devenu
beaucoup plus supportable parce qu'il ne
fait pas aussi froid qu'avant et la
chaleur est beaucoup plus intense
l'une des conséquences de ces fortes
chaleurs des coupures de courant dues à
la surconsommation des climatiseurs
mardi pas moins de sept cent mille
foyers dans la capitale étaient
concernés par cette panne massive
entraînée par la rupture d'une ligne de
haute tension
la chaleur a augmenté au cours des vingt
trente dernières années l'hiver est de
même beaucoup plus supportable parce
qu'il ne fait pas aussi froid qu'avant
et la chaleur est beaucoup plus un
tailleur dans le monde l'australie est
également en alerte rouge avec des
températures extrêmes en plein été
austral le thermomètre affiche et 57
degrés dans plusieurs villes ce mercredi
comme à rob bourne dans le nord ouest du
pays la température la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée depuis 62 ans selon
le bureau de météorologie de l'état
australien malgré un retour à la normale
dans les prochains jours de telles
températures pourraient devenir courante
selon les spécialistes
la tendance à long terme malgré les
hauts et les bas malgré les phénomènes
climatiques est très claire les
températures vont continuer à monter
aussi longtemps que continuons à
augmenter la quantité de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère
les engagements de réductions
d'émissions pris par les différents pays
dont ceux annoncés à la coop 26 en
novembre dernier laisse entrevoir un
réchauffement de 2,7 degrés un résultat
bien en-deça des objectifs de l'accord
de paris
et la température est montée cet après
midi à bamako aux manifestations
toujours en cours ce soir de plusieurs
centaines de personnes pour protester
contre les sanctions de la cedeao visant
le mali un appel à la mobilisation lancé
par les militaires au pouvoir
une protestation pour dénoncer les
mesures punitives de l'organisation
ouest africaine et les conséquences sur
le quotidien des maliens l'instance
régionale continue de mettre la pression
sur les généraux de l'armée pour qu'ils
établissent à un calendrier électoral
raccourcis permettant de transférer le
pouvoir à la société civile de plus
rapidement possible des sanctions
soutenu par l'union européenne cette
dernière annonce d'ailleurs vouloir
rester au mali mais je cite pas à
n'importe quel prix d'après les mots
tout à l'heure de jean yves le drian le
chef de la diplomatie française qui
s'est exprimé à l'occasion d'un sommet
informel des ministres européens des
affaires étrangères réunis depuis hier à
brest en bretagne 1
et comme l'a dit josette borel nous
sommes
déterminés à soutenir la cedeao dans
l'appui à ces démarches et la mise en
oeuvre des mesures qui ont été décidées
à la fois dans le gel des appuis
budgétaires qu'ils soient européens ou
qu'ils soient nationaux puisque
lorsqu'il concerne la france ça sera le
cas
à condition que cela ne porte pas
atteinte à la population et donc les
opérations liées au développement seront
maintenus nous sommes et nous voulons
rester au mali mais pas à n'importe quel
prix et nous sommes somalie pour
combattre le terrorisme et pas pour
autre chose puisqu'il y a aujourd'hui
des manifestations à bamako
et puisque là la raison qui est invoquée
par la junte
d'allonger la transition
jusque durée de cinq ans la raison qui
est invoqué des raisons de sécurité
il rompt ne peut pas procéder à des
votes parce que nous sommes pas en
sécurité
je pense que si on est en sécurité pour
manifester on doit sûrement être en
sécurité pour voter autres pays
africains ou autres manifestations à la
tunisie qui célèbre aujourd'hui les onze
ans de sa révolution de jasmin les
festivités et les rassemblements ont été
interdits par le gouvernement que 8,19
oblige interdiction bravée par plusieurs
centaines de manifestants estimant que
cette décision est plus politique que
sanitaire quelques heurts ont opposé les
militants aux forces de l'ordre la
correspondance à tunis a signé bassam
chimie
c'est un anniversaire qui aura été
marquée par des tensions entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre en
plein coeur de la capitale tunisienne ce
vendredi 14 janvier alors que tout
rassemblement avait été interdit par les
autorités pour des raisons sanitaires en
pleine crise de coronavirus plusieurs
centaines de tunisiens ont bravé un
important dispositif de sécurité pour
marquer leur opposition au président
kaïs sayed et les mesures d'exception
mises en place à l'issue de son coup de
force du 25 juillet dernier les
manifestants qui ont réussi à briser le
cordon de sécurité ont été dispersés à
coup de matraques et de gaz lacrymogènes
par les forces de l'ordre présentes en
masse dans le coeur de la capitale
plusieurs associations et partis
politiques avaient maintenu leur appel à
manifester invoquant une
instrumentalisation politique de la
situation sanitaire pour anéantir ce qui
reste des droits et des libertés
fondamentales
ennahda et ettakatol ou encore le
courant démocrate étaient présents pour
ces rassemblements certains d'entre eux
ont évoqué des violences policières
inacceptable écouter
quand nous nous sommes rendus sur la
place jean jaurès ils ont commencé à
nous malmener en faisant usage de la
violence avec leurs matraques et en
faisant usage également de grenades de
désencerclement ça nous a donné
l'impression d'être en guerre contre un
état colonial dans notre propre pays il
ya eu des violences policières d'être
mois contre des députés mais surtout
contre les jeunes dont certains ont été
arrêtés c'est pour cela qu'on est venus
ici pour discuter avec le chef de la
police pour qui la paix le ministre de
l'intérieur et lui demande la libération
immédiate de ces jeunes arrêtés
des émeutes à tunis et malheureusement
l'image de notre pays à l'étranger vient
d'être lourdement entachée on les dit et
ça nous on n'en voulait pas nous
souhaitons une manifestation pacifique
et joyeuse et aujourd'hui vous voyez
notre cher police comment elle traite
les citoyens et les élus de la
république des tensions se sont calmées
aux alentours de 16 heures et les rues
du centre-ville rouverte à la
circulation malgré la présence toujours
aussi importante des forces de l'ordre
les tunisiens n'avaient pas le coeur à
la fête pour cet anniversaire morose du
14 janvier dans un pays en pleine crise
politique et économique un thème nafti
est l'auteur de l' ouvrage de la
révolution à la restauration où va la
tunisie aux éditions riveneuve il estime
que les décisions récentes de kaïs saïd
sont loin d'être anodines
tout et c'est pour
pour que les manifestations se passe mal
j'ai mis le feu aux poudres c'est les
déclarations du gouverneur donc
l'équivalent du préfet de tunis qui a
très proche du président qui a bien
expliqué qu' il était effectivement été
porter allégeance faille prêter
allégeance au président de la république
et s'en est pris à l'opposition donc
sortant totalement de son rôle de deux
grands commis de l'état donc s'est
clairement positionné et si on avait un
doute sur sur cette interdiction les
doutes ont été dissipées par les prises
de positions très hostile aux
manifestants aussi bien du gouverneur de
tunis que du ministère de l'intérieur
donc moi c'est clair c'est politique le
président de la république a décidé de
manière unilatérale en décembre qu'il
fallait commémorer le 17 décembre est
pas le 14 janvier et c'est ce n'est pas
anodin c'est c'est le fond même de sa de
son idéologie parce qu'il estime que
tout ce qui a été entrepris à partir du
14 janvier donc à partir de la fuite de
ben ali et à raser et à recommencer
moscou rejette ce soir les accusations
du site gratuite américaines selon
lesquelles la russie aurait
prépositionné des agents en ukraine et
ce dans l'optique d'une présumée
opérations de sabotage censé servir de
prétexte pour une invasion russe après
trois rounds de négociations cette
semaine à genève bruxelles et vienne et
tension ne retombe pas alors que le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
donné tout à l'heure sa traditionnelle
conférence de presse annuelle la
correspondance à moscou d'antonne
clairoix
pendant près de 2h30 sergueï lavrov a
évoqué de très nombreux sujets en lien
avec les événements qui font l'actualité
internationale et qui ont fait
l'actualité tout au long de l'année 2020
l'ukraine a bien entendu été sujette à
plusieurs questions ce qui a permis au
ministre russe de rappeler les lignes
rouges défini par moscou
nous sommes catégoriquement contre
la présence de le temps à côté de notre
frontière y compris compte tenu du cap
menée par les autorités ukrainiennes je
parle des autorités présidente et des
autorités d'aujourd'hui malheureusement
de plus c'est une vraie ligne rouge
et ils s'en rendent compte ensuite
deuxièmement si l'ukraine n'est pas
membre de le temps on pourrait parler
des accords bilatéraux avec les
américains les britanniques et d'autres
pays occidentaux
qui crée des objets militaires qui ouvre
des bases sur la mer d'azov c'est aussi
une situation inacceptable pour nous on
l'a constaté cette semaine des
représentants russes se sont entretenus
avec des représentants américains des
représentants de l'otan ou encore de
l'eau et soeurs mais aucun dialogue
direct avec l'union européenne alors
qu'il est pourtant question ici de la
stabilité stratégique et sécuritaire du
continent européen sergey lavrov nous
explique pourquoi
regrettant que l'union européenne depuis
sept ans est détruite tous les meilleurs
mécanismes
sur tous les mécanismes dans lequel en
discuter des aspects pratiques de
l'assurance de la sécurité
maintenant nous sommes adressés aux
états unis et a le temps
en fait
même sur le papier nous avons encore les
relations avec ces organisations l'acte
fondateur par exemple et avec les
collègues européens nous avons gelé tous
nos accords
c'est plutôt inquiétant qu'il faut
adresser à josé barel et aux membres de
l'union européenne
toujours à propos des garanties de
sécurité demandées par la russie le
ministre des affaires étrangères a fait
savoir que les propositions russes
n'était pas un menu dans lequel on
pouvait choisir une ou deux lignes mais
plutôt un ensemble un paquet de mesures
à part entière pour sergueï lavrov il ne
s'agit pas pour les partenaires
européens de prendre parti pour tel ou
tel côté pour tel ou tel acteur mais
plutôt de négocier ensemble sur des
garanties de sécurité de manière adulte
cette conférence de presse aura donc été
le très dense de très nombreux sujets
ont auront été évoqué les relations
entre la russie et différents pays je
peux par exemple citer les relations
entre la russie et la chine le japon
l'irak ou encore la finlande ont été
abordés lors de cette conférence de
presse sergueï lavrov ainsi pu réitérer
lors de cet exercice la fermeté de la
position russe sur les gages sur la
demande de gages sérieux et écrits
concernant l'expansion plus tôt l'arrêt
de l'expansion vers l'est vers les
frontières russes et l'arrêt des
activités de l'otan aux frontières de la
russie
retour en france avec edf mise à
contribution pour limiter la facture des
français malgré l'augmentation des cours
de l'électricité liée à la reprise
économique le gouvernement maintient sa
position du mois de septembre et
confirme qu'il limitera l'augmentation
du prix de l'électricité à 4% en 2022
après avoir réduit au maximum le coût de
la principale texte l'exécutif va aussi
contraindre edf à augmenter à titre
explose exceptionnel son volume
d'électricité nucléaire vendu à prix
réduits à ses concurrents
la facture d'électricité des français
n'augmentera pas de plus de 4 % sur
toute l'année 2022 nous allons mettre en
oeuvre une mesure complémentaire en
augmentant de 20 térawattheures le
volume d'électricité nucléaire vendu à
prix réduits par edf à ses concurrents
cette mesure sera automatiquement
répercutée sur la facture des
particuliers
que ce soit les ménages ou les
entreprises qui achètent leur
électricité aux tarifs régulés cela
représentera un coût pour edf compris
entre 7,7 milliards et 8,4 milliards
d'euros en fonction des prix de marché
il n'y aura pas de rattrapage conduisant
à une nouvelle hausse en 2023 ce sont
l'état et edf qui supporteront le coût
de cette mesure une annonce du ministre
de l'économie bruno le maire qui est
elle engage à tenir ses engagements
selon hélène la porte elle est la porte
parole de la candidate fn à l'élection
présidentielle marine le pen c'est une
promesse qui a été faite par le
gouvernement qui devrait plafonner à 4%
dose d'énergie on est à quelques mois la
présence y est mais c'est surtout au
delà ça préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
français qui déjà mises à rude épreuve
je rappelle en même temps qu'il ya un
sondage une étude plutôt de secours
populaire qui indique qu'un français sur
quatre ne mange pas à sa faim l'énergie
c'est un produit de luxe c'est un
produit de nécessité
se chauffer ça fait partie des choses
qui sont enfin qui sont indispensables à
la vie de chacun donc oui les le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix mais j'ai
envie de dire c'est surtout être correct
et honnête vis-à-vis de ce qui était
promis aux français mais c'est surtout
la méthode - finalement qui me gêne
derrière sur comment est mise en place
cette mesure même bruno le maire est
d'accord avec nous sur ce point là on ne
peut pas continuer laisser bruxelles
réglementée à l'intérieur de notre pays
la tarification des tristes et notamment
et c'est la fin de cette édition on se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes à
21h restés sur leur terre france
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france fois et à la rivière là il ya
tout et c'est un peu dégueulasse
mais sa voix dit peiné kawase l'onu
kawachi taux
passé unités et midi elle vient même pas
de pain
donc la jolie de mai une compote qui est
bien sûr fait est-ce que vous avez une
idée de qui sont ces gens qui attaquent
un lycée
ça va
sariska ans
[Musique]
chapeau
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment que l'on est assis sur une
poudrière moi je leur jette même pas la
pierre c'est bien d'accueillir mais je
cassais un mot leur donne de l'espoir et
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers bah écoute
accroche-toi mais j'ai pas de conneries
pour une fois qu'on a la parole a aussi
dit mais est-ce que ce qu'on leur a
apporté est ce que ce système là ce
qu'il est bon pour moi notre gros point
d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ses habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]